hey guys its desktop Patterson kara and
I'm David Griffin your resident comic
book and video game guru and this is our
review of the walking dead season 4
episode 13 alone so I thought this
episode is okay I thought it was better
than last week's episode yes you know we
had talked about like it's better if
they move along the plot and also weave
in all the different characters and this
episode did it not heavy on the plot you
know they're still there still I'm not
saying they're still not stretching out
it just wasn't a stretch out as last
week's episodes was bad this was this
was better I like you know get to see a
lot more people second week in a row now
not seeing any Rick and Carl and
Michonne so a second time they've done
that or Tyrese or tell ya I know I
thought this episode we would have
gotten some Tyrese but we didn't I miss
basically the whole point episode was to
get everybody I thought that was last
week because yeah again to get everybody
moving towards the town yes looking
toward a terminus terminus is sanctuary
and we get to see you know some of you
point this out to me before we have to
see deal runs into the this group called
the hunters I think that's what they're
trying to be from the comic books I know
you haven't gotten quite that far man
works but that's who those guys are so I
mean yeah I just getting everybody
moving towards the town what I hope
doesn't happen and kind of afraid that
it's gonna end it's gonna edit the town
no no that's not what I'm afraid of what
I'm afraid of is they all get their
relatively around the same time well cuz
I gotta I gotta call [ __ ] on that
right come on really you guys get all
spread apart right you know with all
different circumstances with different
people and somehow you get to the same
place around the same time I know
they're not gonna like come in there
exactly but within a day or two or a few
days I don't buy it you know it'd be
weeks or months between finding a place
like that there is a hopefully maybe
somebody will be there ahead of time and
then little like they'll be the voice be
like oh this is gonna work we could make
it work here as they always do in the
walking dead of course that always goes
to crap but then again terminus is
something I'm not sure where they going
with this story lines i'm not trying to
spoil anything from the comics i don't
know but uh what I there was a scene
that I thought they could have done
better in the series and it's just
because I recently in the last year read
Cormac McCarthy's the road
and I guess if you don't to be spoiled
by this one dimension I'm gonna mention
one scene from that book there's a scene
where you know the movie had Viggo
Mortensen and the book is the same thing
where I'm he and his son had this one
moment where they come across like Daryl
and Beth they come across this bunker
well this food and you know just good
stuff and they have like one really good
night together in this a
post-apocalyptic world and like it's
special the next day they had to move on
from that I wish Derril and best would
have spent in wharton I don't want a
whole episode to the hero but I'm not
asking for that but like I wish I would
have had more time in that house I felt
like it was too rushed and just seeing
all those zombies come in at the last
minute more zombies it's like it'd be
cool to have a little bit of respite
from the zombies and every scene has to
be about zombies almost killing
everybody like I wished it because the
comic takes breaks from that is you
ready no the comic takes breaks from
them being attacked by zombies and I
wish we lived gotten a break from that
instead of her getting carried off to
who knows where but yeah it was a big
fan of all the pic it back in and you
know carrying like oh like a wife right
they had held the hand-holding cuz you
guys corrected me she is 28 years old
even though she looks like she's 18 but
yeah the question is more of what the
character is supposed to be on this
right I know why people have mentioned
like oh she's 20 wait well she's not 28
on the show let's go yeah at 28 on the
show no way no way she's not supposed to
be 28 years old yeah it's a Darrell on
the show would probably be like 30 32 I
mean show a show age he would be that
out so yeah I mean it's a modern family
type of situation right cuz a girl one
of the daughters from the door for
modern families like 20-some
twenty-something but she's just first
year in college in 1990 right yeah so I
mean this was a better episode last week
for sure but again the series for me
it's just it's still meandering it's
still dragging out and yes they do great
action sequences they do cool scenes you
know that the scene in the fog you know
with Maggie Maggie Bob Bob and Sasha
that was a good scene always good act
but it's like again what does it do for
the story what does it do for care to
develop I know fans of the show argue
that is character development I'm like I
don't know watch a show like true
detective I don't really see character
development in a scene of the fog where
somebody I just don't see there was a
little character development Bob just
showing his path I like that issue I did
I feel sure I like to how he was because
we assumed that he'd come with with what
call it right that one forgot the name
of it that came from oh yeah right yeah
that's what I assume but now when we
find that they actually had found him he
had been alone by himself and I did like
the opening that was kind of a nice
scene so there was a little and then you
know there's a relationship between him
and Sasha that i enjoyed liked seeing
their relationship what was Maggie doing
lying on the ground in that one town I
don't get there I don't get it and I
mean it's just that whole sequence is
we're like oh all of a sudden the
windows gone yes it crashes she wakes up
pops up like oh and then like all these
Walker made no sense at all seemed it
didn't feel right i don't know why was
she lying on the ground there when she
try and go in that building yeah get to
high ground you're the high can also set
up a perimeter non laid out in the
middle of the street like Baby Doe buddy
although I'm not dead you know yeah that
was a weird scene I didn't get that I
know how sometimes the show i I just I
want to know what worries about the
show's I don't think this show has a
clear direction they have the comics to
go after go off of but this isn't like a
game of thrones this isn't Lord of the
Rings isn't Harry Potter they're not
following to an end point Robert
Kirkman's has said that he'll write this
as long as you can write it which
bothers me I don't like I think some of
the best comic book series and early
Brian cable he's gonna write as long as
he gets money and then AMC has said we
hope the show can go on as long as it
can I don't like hearing that again it's
all about the Greens I wasn't get that
green I want to I want to know they have
an endgame you said lost got really good
after season three because they knew
what the orders at end of season three
they cuz they they had to take a hiatus
right in the beginning because season
three was kind of like this season we're
like they just have these episodes and
really didn't do anything didn't know
when the show is ending and then finally
they took a break and then they had a
discussion with ABC and said what do you
know how long we're gonna have this show
that way we can plot out everything and
once they did then they came back in the
second half of season three was really
good and on me I mean season six had its
problems but I felt like the second half
season three and four and five or they
actually had movement on everybody and
walking dead right now is kind of just
treading water and that's what I'm
curious if it's gonna be a show every
week where they just see who can survive
this
experience and that show to me becomes a
little old I just don't have any Oh game
it's like a video games like can we
survive this level to get to the boss
fight i'm like i don't i don't want to
watch that on television I want a little
more story you know and I think that's
what's been bothering by like i said i
love the cast i like the way it's shot I
like the look of it a look kind of old
school with the film the grain I like
the way it looks but I just don't want I
needed more of a story then just don't
think I'm getting that right now but
that's just my opinion if you like the
show please keep liking it oh I'm
wondering now with the funeral home
whether or not we're gonna find out who
was living yeah right who took Beth I'm
assuming whoever was living the funeral
home had something to do with making
Beth maybe for safety reasons right
maybe he felt like but then at the same
time she did drop her stuff so if it was
for safety reasons I don't know probably
gotta yeah I did like Darrell's when he
saw the the pigs feet in the diet sodas
like you would he say white trash brush
my tribe Roger that made me laugh yeah I
did Darrell's a man there was great so
this episode yeah I thought it was all
right last winter than last week just
improvement you know for sure so know
hopefully we'll see more there's only
three episodes left then Game of Thrones
hey all right guys you can let us know
what you thought of this episode you can
post your comments below on the website
think hero.com or on our youtube channel
think aeropro also come check us out on
Twitter tell us what we thought about
this week's episodes like last week's
better or this week's where do you think
I'm is gonna happen when everybody gets
to the town we can find us at think hero
i'm at griffin de and we asked on the
facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think carroll fans and make sure you
like that page and share our videos and
subscribe to our YouTube channel think
euro pro alright thanks
you